>>Reto Meier: Hello everyone.
My name is Reto Meier and welcome to This
Week in Android Development.
Last week in Android Development Live, Roman,
Nick and Adam hosted the record breaking premier
of Android Design and Action and taking a
look at these three transit apps and giving
them a full UI makeover.
On the Friday's Game Review, Dan Galpin was
joined by returning co host, Ian Ni-Lewis,
for a look at these five games in a no holds
barred game review showdown.
On the App Clinic, Ian and I put timer and
stopwatch apps under the microscope.
Video for each of these broadcasts is now
available on YouTube.
You can find links to all of last week's broadcasts,
our entire back catalog and the schedule for
this week's shows at Google Developers Live;
that's Developers.Google.com/live/Android.
This week we have seven shows for your viewing
pleasure starting with the Android Developer
Office Hours broadcasting live from London,
Mount View and Sydney.
On Tuesday Android Design and Action will
be back at 10:30am Eastern Time to take a
look at two of the timer, stopwatch apps we
reviewed on last Friday's app clinic.
Join Nick and Adam as they offer some alternative
UX implementations for Impetus Interval Timer
and Hybrid Stopwatch.
On Thursday, we have the premier of Developer's
Strike Back, an opportunity for developers
whose apps we pulled apart on the app clinic
and Android Design and Action, to respond
to our candid feedback and let us know a little
more about the challenges they faced building
their apps and how they overcame them.
On Friday, Ian is breaking out his prescription
less glasses and thumb ring for an App Clinic
on camera and photography apps.
We'll be coming to you at a brand new time
of 10:30am Pacific, that's two and a half
hours earlier than normal.
There's more to these apps than hipster filters,
though, so be sure to visit the moderator
page linked here and nominate your suggestions.
Also at a brand new time is the Friday's Game
Review with professional hat enthusiast, Dan
Galpin, who will once again be joined by Ian,
“I can't get enough time on Camera”, Ni-Lewis.
Once again this week there's no theme so hit
us up on the moderator page to nominate any
game for the guys to review.
In other Android developer news you can catch
some Android developer advocates live in person;
Rio [unclear], Tony and Ankur will be attending
the GDG Seoul Meetup on Sunday at 6pm and
David Chandler will be visiting the Richmond
Java User Group this Wednesday at 5:30.
In Android documentation last week, we saw
the publication of a new developer and testing
checklist for adding accessibility support
to your apps as well as the launching filter
provided by device for ABI support for multi
APK distribution.
We also announce that Android activations
have hit the half billion milestone and are
happy to report that the Jelly Bean statue
was returned to its rightful place in front
of building 44.
In new and update apps this week, check out
social augmentation app Sonar and the new
update from weather app classic, the Weather
Channel.
That's all for this week in Android Development,
my name is Reto Meier, thanks for watching.